let me put it this way if one year from
now you're not using dark mail it's
because you enjoy knowing that the NSA
is reading your unencrypted emails
hi I'm Zach Weiss molar for reason TV
we're here with Ladera Levison owner uh
lavabit the email service that was used
by former NSA contractor Edward Snowden
after Snowden's identity was revealed
Levison shut down the service and put up
a message on his website saying that to
keep it running would force him to
become complicit in crimes against the
American people with our thank you very
much for talking to us thank you for
having me Zach I'm hoping that by the
time I die I'll be known for more than
just being Edward Snowden's email
provider well before we get into that
and before we get into what these crimes
against the American people might have
been I want to just address the fact
that for several months after you shut
down the service you weren't allowed to
speak a detail about why you had to do
this was being under that kind of gag
order hard and frustrating for you Oh
certainly if I had been able to talk
about what had transpired I may not have
had to shut down my service the thing
about our country is that if you're
allowed to speak your lap you at least
have the ability the opportunity to
change the circumstances of your
situation and I wasn't afforded that
opportunity we're talking about some of
the worst abuse of prior restraint on
speech that I can imagine and there's
still details about this case that I
can't discuss that I would like to now
that said come October the most
important detail about the case was
unsealed primarily because I had managed
to muster the resources to appeal and
that detail was that they were demanding
my SSL key and that they wanted to use
that key to masquerade as lavabit on the
Internet it's important to point out
that lavabit part of the appeal of it
was that it had extra levels of
encryption that were supposed to prevent
third parties from being able to look in
and snoop on what's being sent back and
forth I mean I'm assuming even you were
not able to look at you know the goal of
my service was really to remove the
service provider from
surveillance equation that is to say
there was nothing I could do to protect
messages before they arrived at my
server or once they got onto a person's
home computer but what I focused on was
ensuring that while they were stored on
my servers they would be protected and
what the feds did is they wanted to
intercept the users password so that
they could access those contents stored
on disk access the contents before they
were encrypted and I had a real problem
with that particularly since they were
going to be doing it so indiscriminately
and without any kind of transparency
back to me now presumably users who were
not under investigation their
communications would have been filtered
out but of course the FBI and it was the
FBI not the NSA that I was dealing with
in this case we're completely unwilling
to provide any kind of transparency or
auditing capability back to me to
confirm that that was in fact what they
were doing you're saying that you were
willing to comply with some of their
requests what made you what why would
you even work with them on that limited
question personally I felt I had no
obligation to collect that information
and I had no obligation to turn those
keys over but when faced with a
protracted legal battle over whether or
not they could collect my SSL keys and
realizing that if I lost that battle I
would have to shut down my server in
order to adhere to my own moral ethical
and political principles and balance
that against the harm it would do to the
other 400,000 people using my service I
decided that turning over the meta
information that they could have
collected anyways without my SSL key
would have been an appropriate
compromise specifically if I could
guarantee like I said that they were
only able to access the information they
were legally authorized to collect the
timing of the shutdown has led some
people dare I say most people to assume
that the user that they're targeting was
Edward Snowden can you confirm that
today I'm still not allowed legally to
discuss the subject of the investigation
I think it's interesting that the entire
world can speculate on who the subject
was but I who happens to be at the heart
of one of these one aspect of this
overall controversy can't participate in
that same political debate because of
these restrictions on my speech is there
any movement on that to have that
information opened up is there any hope
of that happening in the near future I'm
not quite sure what I can say here okay
but I'm going to go out on a limb and
say that my legal team is trying to get
more of the case unsealed shed more
light onto some of the other proceedings
that occurred in relation to this matter
the subject of the investigation I don't
think is going to be one of the items
that's revealed do you believe that
there's information in these sealed
records that's in the public interest
that should be out in the open certainly
and I think there's information totally
unrelated to this case that I was
exposed to that should be out in the
open but unfortunately I'm not legally
allowed to disclose any of it
what are your thoughts about what Edward
Snowden did certainly I'm happy that the
information that he exposed was revealed
to the public I think they have a right
to know I think it's unfortunate that he
had to be the one to reveal it and not
from official government sources
understanding that these types of
threats exist and prompting a very real
discussion about whether these practices
are right or wrong and what
technological methods we can use to
protect people's communications and mass
have all been triggered by these
disclosures and I think their
discussions that we need to have I think
those of us in the
unity that the security community have
known for a long time that our
government was capable of this we just
didn't think they would actually engage
in this kind of activity effectively
acting like an organized cyber criminal
game do you mention that perhaps these
revelations have made the general public
more aware of the need for security
technologies encryption technology do
you think that these sort of tools are
gonna start going mainstream now Oh
certainly yeah I can say in the month
leading up to my shutdown paid
registrations jumped by two and a half
times oh wow you know it was my best
month on record and immediately after
that best month on record while my
revenue was continuing to climb I had to
shut down Wow so I mean to walk away
from that and that's an easy and to go
against something as powerful as the
federal government that seems like an
incredibly difficult and trying task
what made me decide to do that when I
shut down my big fear was that they were
gonna show up arrest me confiscate all
my servers and start rummaging through
the 50 million or so messages that were
stored on them many of which belonged to
free account holders that were
unencrypted I figured if I was lucky in
a couple of months I would be out
searching for a job I never expected
people to take notice the way they did
and I think it only goes to show just
what kind of climate were living in now
after all of the disclosures this past
summer and it just goes to show how much
of an awareness we have and I can
probably thank some of my higher profile
users for drawing so much attention this
is a business that you spent 10 years of
your life building it was on its way up
you walked away from it do you regret
doing that do you think that you did the
right thing
oh I know I did the right thing now when
I shut down I knew I was making the
right decision in accordance with my own
moral beliefs I wasn't sure
my user base would understand the public
would understand I was afraid they would
focus on the the government's claim that
they were only going to be looking at a
handful of users and not realize just
how wrong i thought this was and the
public reaction has really reinforced my
belief that what they were trying to do
was wrong and that they were trying to
keep it secret to avoid having to pay
the political price for what they were
trying to do what's it like going up
against the most powerful government in
the world I mean is that frightening to
you are you it do you ever get scared or
is it frustration what what do you feel
on a day to day basis when you're
thinking about going against the federal
government the United States I try not
to think about it certainly there's an
element of fear but from my perspective
you're not supposed to be afraid of your
own government particularly if you're
doing nothing wrong and I wasn't
breaking the law I wasn't doing anything
wrong
now I realized that there were members
of the Department of Justice that
wouldn't share that view and that might
come after me no matter what but I had
to hold true to my beliefs it was
precisely what that statement on my
website said I did not want to become
complicit in crimes against the American
people because if you assume that
snooping on Americans in mass is in fact
a crime then providing or facilitating
access to those communications and not
telling anybody that you were being
forced to do it would be complicit in
that crime and I I truly believe that
and I felt it was my obligation I so to
speak higher obligation than that of a
national law to not be complicit in that
and the best I could do at the time was
shut down you in collaboration with
silent circle which is another encrypted
email and security service that shut
down their email
the wake of the NSA revelations are
creating a new venture called dark mail
what is dark mail what can when can we
expect to see it and how is it different
and how will you avoid the pitfalls of
what happened with lavabit lavabit and
silent circle both employed encryption
technology on the server we relied on
SSL to provide an encrypted bridge
between a user's home computer and the
server that allowed us to secure
people's communications without needing
to change any of the legacy email
protocols that we've been using since
the 1970s dark mail is really sort of
the admission that that model no longer
works and that what we truly need to do
is push the encryption down to a
person's computer to their smartphone to
effectively remove the service provider
from the surveillance equation by making
technologically impossible for them to
access the contents of an email so my
device would be doing the actual
encrypting not on a network exactly and
where the difficulty comes in is
building a set of protocols and systems
behind it that facilitate that process
so that everybody can take advantage of
it who do you see using this as this
something as a general buddy okay
mom pop grandma you're out I really
think that this is the future of
communications that we've realized in
the last year that unless you're
encrypting stuff on your device
specifically to a key that only the
other party that you're intending to
communicate with can decrypt then you
can't assume it's secure so why would
mom pop grandma use encrypted email a
lot of people just don't see the need
for it they say I don't have anything to
hide let me put it this way if one year
from now you're not using dark mail it's
because you enjoy knowing that the NSA
is reading your unencrypted emails all
of this kind of
rests on the proposition that the
average person still cares about privacy
and a lot of the cultural trends seem to
be pointing in the other direction
everybody posts everything on Facebook
and Twitter and everything is public do
you think depends on your definition of
privacy to me privacy is about retaining
control about what other people learn
about yourself and I think what we're
about to see is an emergence of a new
set of standards and technologies that
return that control to the user so we
have all these NSA revelations and
people might be wondering what should I
do with all this information what in
your mind what are the best ways to
fight back against NSA surveillance I
think they're really three avenues three
battlefield so to speak there's the
legal front the courtroom or certainly
I'm doing everything I can to restore
trust in our internet service providers
but I can only really address one small
portion of an a much larger issue with
my case there's the technological front
where I'm working to develop a new set
of standards that will hopefully
alleviate this problem at least when it
comes to email but ultimately I think
this is really an issue that needs to be
addressed in the political with Congress
taking action and really setting the bar
for what is right and what is wrong when
it comes to government surveillance and
the only way that's going to happen is
if the American public makes it known
clearly known what we want our tax
dollars being used to do our we okay
with billions of American tax dollars
being spent to spy on millions of
Americans
personally I prefer if my money was used
in a slightly different way well dar
Levison thank you very much for talking
to us thank you for having me Zak for
Reason TV I'm Zak why smaller